humanity's struggle against death has
been our most enduring fight
history has given us one weapon in this
existential battle
we fight back with medicine
tens of thousands of years ago our
ancestors scavenged the natural world
for remedies imagine the incredible
leaps of faith we had to take in an
effort to ease the pain
mend the broken revive the sick
medicine was a dark art full of false
starts
and false gods when we struck upon
some form of relief it swept like
wildfire through humankind
we built on every success until medicine
became a form of science
that's when we discovered the real
killers within us
microscopic armies hidden within our
bodies waging
war on our species for thousands of
years
medicine is our great weapon to fight
back against invisible
unthinkable death
[Applause]
from superstition to science medicine
has become one of humanity's most
powerful tools
and though with each new challenge we
may stumble find a way to get
stronger and smarter
to beat back fatal diseases and extend
our lifespans
even crack open our genetic code
this is the story of how our fight
against death has determined our fate
how it became the driving force of our
evolution
how our tireless pursuit of medicine has
made us
moderate and even made us super human
this is origins
it's the greatest adventure story ever
told the story of humankind
how we created the modern world we're
going back in time to explore
key moments origin moments that change
the course of our shared history
in the beginning survival was key not
just from the violent threat of instant
death posed by predators
survival from all the little things that
we take for granted today
infection bacteria disease let's be
honest any time before the last
century a common cold or a bug bite
could kill you
medicine is the name that we gave to the
magic that allowed us to cheat
death again and again and again
how we learned to fight how we have
managed to survive
in fact all the little miracles that
medicine brings us today
all of it adds up to a story about who
we are
as a species these are moments in
time origin moments that offer
irrefutable proof
medicine has made us modern and it's
been a key weapon in our fight for
survival for
thousands of years
we didn't know how old medicine was
until 1991.
imagine you're hiking through the
eastern alps and you spot something in
the snow
it's an ancient mummy the oldest best
preserved corpse
in history we call him otzi man
and he's more than 5 300 years old
ultimate has given us an understanding
of the origins of medicine
when we evaluated him we're able to
document ancient humans best efforts at
treating the human body
so utsi man has given us a glimpse on
how he lived
but we also got an understanding of how
he died
[Music]
otsi man lived in a time of brutality
between humans
ancient tribes often fought to the death
of her life's most precious resources
[Applause]
ah
we know otzi was a fighter from the
scars on his body
but we also know that he and his tribe
were true believers
in the mysterious healing powers of
nature
medicine was largely a matter of
whatever was at hand
herbs tree bark those kind of things
that may have a
healing effect but it was really kind of
catch as catch can
[Music]
today we're inventing medicines in the
laboratory
to do that we need thousands of years of
trial and error
plants and nature are the foundation of
modern medicine
lived in a world of unforgiving violence
but otzi man and his people
had learned the earth had remedies for
their pain
natural therapies passed down from
generation to generation
each one improving on the last
put his trust his faith in the healing
powers of the earth
but natural medicine could not protect
him from human brutality
[Music]
did
[Music]
[Music]
bootsy man was found face down the flint
arrowhead in his shoulder
we think he died of blunt force trauma
to the head
ot man comes from a farming community
that was only
5 000 years into modern man
as a 45 year old shepherd ot man is a
living document so to speak
of the good and the bad of those
societies
in some sense the agricultural economy
that they were living in
was great in terms of letting them
flourish and have stable
lives and growing families
but then they had to come to grips with
what are called mismatched diseases
such as tooth disease dental disease
heart disease
all of those things that we now think of
as human life and kind of what a lot of
people die from
is attributable to the civilization
we've created
all of a sudden otzi and his people were
faced with new diseases
because of the invention of agriculture
they needed new remedies
and their only resource is the natural
world around them
woodsy man is sort of a champion
survivalist it's a testament to how well
he did that he made it into the 40s
given how harsh the environment must
have been in his stomach there were eggs
of parasites
his toes had remnants of frostbite he
didn't have the medical firepower we do
now
but he carried with him essentially a
first aid kit inside it was a mushroom
birch polypore which could have been a
treatment for his intestinal parasite
everyone thought that these ancient folk
remedies from thousands of years ago had
nothing left to teach us
but now that these synthetic drugs have
reached a plateau scientists are
beginning to realize
that maybe in order to go forwards we
need to go backwards
and discover what nature has to offer us
today
we're inventing medicines in the
laboratory but the best medicines the
most effective medicines
were discovered from nature we learn
from plants
and nature and then we go to the
laboratory and try to copy them
our ancestors surprisingly modern and
inventive medical treatments
have left scientists scouring the earth
and reaching back in time
for forgotten cures
about 80 of the world's population
relies on plants
as a major form of medicine looking
around in this habitat you might see
just some trees and weeds and not really
think that there's anything special
about this area
but what i see is different i see
medicines i
see cures from the past and hopefully
for our future
the brazilian pepper tree berry has a
unique mechanism
of action that we've just started to
uncover
it could be the source of the next big
medicine
and treating really nasty infections
like mrsa
in the future
plants make these compounds to protect
themselves
it works not by killing the bacteria
but by disarming it so we're harnessing
tools that are already in use to manage
human infections
we're not looking for a needle in a
haystack
we know that people have used these
plants as medicines
for hundreds and hundreds of years
every traditional society had
encyclopedic knowledge
of the medicinal properties of the
plants
in their environment because that was
the only medicine they had
during the american civil war soldiers
would make teas
out of the oak bark and use it to rinse
their wounds and infections
spanish moss has also been used as a tea
to treat fever
and chills so all around us
we actually are surrounded by many
interesting
plants that could serve as future
medicines
a lot of this information which may seem
bizarre
folk medicine to us in fact is
pharmaceutically potentially extremely
valuable
i think there are many many more areas
of medicine that can benefit
from improving our understanding of how
these ancient remedies actually work
these days we can treat wounds and cure
diseases that not too long ago would
have meant
certain death but the medical skills
that made us who we are today
were built by the doctor who got his
start the hard way
patching up gladiators in a second
century fight club
[Music]
humanity is cursed by the knowledge of
our own mortality
the terrifying realization that life is
a fickle flame
that we and all our loved ones are
destined for the grave
drives us to find solace religion told
us death
is not the end flesh is weak but the
soul survives
we could be reborn in infinite loops of
reincarnation
or live forever in the kingdom of heaven
to our ancestors religion offered more
than solace
it offered to cure our suffering
for thousands of years we invoked the
supernatural in search of remedies
medicine and superstition were woven
tightly together
turned to divination shamans and white
witches to guide us to long
life for the ancients no remedy
was too strange
[Music]
the egyptians mixed spells and natural
cures into magical remedies
they pioneered bloodletting a pure all
around the world for 2 000 years
even in our deepest desperation we
pushed on
slowly uncovering the truth behind our
suffering
the pain of losing loved ones drove us
forward
over time the answers began to reveal
themselves
superstition is giving way to science
medical science has come a long way in
the last century
to our ancestors things like ct scans
and laser surgery might look like magic
the medical skills that made us who we
are today were built on a slow and
steady accumulation of knowledge
over centuries
medical knowledge the world over came to
a head here
in ancient greece an empire of organized
learning where the ruins of medical
treatment centers
still stand today if you are going to be
sick in the ancient world
i think you really want to be treated by
the ancient greeks for one thing
they had temples of healing these were
called esclepion
which were basically the world's first
teaching hospitals
[Music]
so we're here in the most famous
sanatorium of the ancient world in the
sanctuary of asclepios
people were cured here by the priests
but not just a priest who might say an
incantation or
wave a piece of smokey feather around
you and hope that the spirits would
leave you
this was based on trial and error
medicine was more than just
magic patients would visit this ancient
teaching hospital
they would actually spend the night and
the next day report their dreams
which guided the doctors to finding the
next treatment
it happened always under the umbrella
of the god but it was a real cure
even surgery they actually invented and
developed scalpels
we can see evidence of minor surgeries
when we look at the patients that were
treated
during that time as time passed
the priests gathering experience they
became
at the end practical doctors real
doctors
this is the real significance
greek medicine it actually created a
structure for human disease and human
experience that we still use
today the greeks created the ritual and
the process of diagnosis
everything that we have today is built
on the giant shoulders of those
that came before us
every step every innovation is held onto
that is the scientific method
but we're continuing to build on a
legacy of thousands and thousands of
years
for the fundamental advances for
tomorrow
this trial and error approach became the
scientific
method the basis of all modern medicine
observe
experiment formulate a hypothesis and
then test it again
and again until it's proven false or
true it's a method passed down to us by
the most famous
graduate of the esclepian galen of
pergamon
roughly 200 years after the birth of
christ
galen helped lay the origins of modern
medicine
galen was a fight doctor who actually
managed to write down
his best practices and writing down what
he knew to be true
he created a corpus that was not just
useful but was in fact revered
for centuries
let's see
noon
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
booster
ghosts
[Applause]
with each procedure galen was diving
into undiscovered territory
lucky for us he kept detailed notes
and recorded all his successes and his
failures
[Applause]
[Music]
be
[Music]
the tradition before galen was so bad
that you were actually genuinely likely
to die if you went to see a doctor
which is why galen himself is such an
important doctor
because he wasn't in there simply to
magic something up and hope for the best
he had a reason for treating a patient
and that patient he expected to get
better starting with galen the history
of medicine is really an effort to
see inside the human body to perceive
what we can't see
his discoveries and his books were
incredibly powerful because it allowed
that
knowledge to be transferred and
disseminated to arabia to
europe eventually and became really the
code of medicine for the next thousand
years
unfortunately all of his autopsies were
done on animals not on humans
for about a thousand years galen colored
modern medicine and the treatments and
people's approaches to it
but there was an awful lot that was
wrong for the principal reason that
galen couldn't do
dissections religion didn't permit
people to do dissections
andrus visayus who is a belgian doctor
he came along at a time when
it became possible to do dissections and
to actually look at human body and how
it was put together
leonardo da vinci for instance with his
anatomical drawings
really began to create an environment in
which medicine and
human anatomy was looked at
scientifically when people
actually studying with essentially with
an open mind
how the body works it's an immensely
complicated thing that we even now we
don't really understand
in a lot of detail i mean nobody really
understands
exactly how the brain is working for
instance but it was the beginning it was
when we started to get
a handle on all this the invention
of the x-ray machine the invention of ct
scans it is
all a process of trying to see what we
could not see
of trying to look inside our bodies
thousands of years ago they only looked
at the surface and then galen got us a
little bit deeper
inside the skin into anatomy when i
think about my surgical practice now
it wouldn't exist if it were not for
galen and now with the tools we have
we're relying on genetics and dna and
even
atomic interactions within our body so
the progress in modern medicine
is in parallel with the progress in
modern technology
they go hand in hand better tools means
a better understanding
of us galen had a seismic effect on how
your doctor treats you
challenging established ideas figuring
out those missteps using science to
prove them wrong
our knowledge base is built on thousands
of years of trial and error
and it all adds up to who we are now we
have mastered the repair of our bodies
we can come back from what was once
deemed
almost certain death and be remade
almost good as new
and yet one enemy is always lurking
always evolving always surprising us
with sickness
and deadly disease we could have been
wiped out as a species if not for a few
origin moments that gave us a fighting
chance against unseen
almost undetectable killers
[Music]
the healers of the past fought blindly
against disease
for ages in the 17th century
their hidden enemy was revealed beneath
the microscope
a strange new world came into focus
we had our first tantalizing glimpse of
the hidden realm
inside us under the lens
flesh became a latticework of nerves
capillaries and blood
each playing a unique role in the
concert of life
everything we thought we knew about
medicine about life itself was cast into
doubt
as we plunged deeper we came face to
face with an alien
universe filled with miniscule creatures
we had revealed the realm of bacteria
[Music]
trillions of them live and die within
every one of us
they are central to our survival yet
among them are the killers
that have plagued us with cholera
tuberculosis and the black death
looking deeper still we discovered
something even more sinister
the virus
secret agents in our system hijack the
mechanics of biology
these microbes are our oldest enemies a
force we have fought
for centuries
over the ages these tiny armies have
killed
billions with medicine we bring the
fight
to them
we live in the information age an epoch
where information can spread to billions
of people around the globe
instantaneously information that can
illuminate
entertain and save lives
in the recent outbreaks of sars measles
and ebola
the transmission of information was
crucial to stop disease in its tracks
but imagine finding yourself stripped of
all access to
information and in the midst of one of
the deadliest plagues known to humankind
where over the course of a few centuries
half of the entire population of europe
was lost this was europe in the 16th
century
the black death stole up to 200 million
lives
it was an invisible relentless tidal
wave washing over the world
for hundreds of years
medicine in the early middle ages in
europe was pretty rudimentary
a lot of it was to do with superstition
rather than any sort of rational
treatment
you might as well have expected if you
had a bad wound to have someone press a
dead rat to it in the hopes that that
would cure it
in 1528 one young doctor was determined
to fight the plague with science his
name was michelle de nostradam
better known as nostradamus when we
think of nostradamus we
think about all his prophecies but
actually he was a plague doctor taking
care of the sick
as a young clinician
we know now the black death is an
infection but back then they didn't know
so they blamed everything from god to
foreigners
and even earthquakes
day
mmm
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
elsie
nostradamus contribution to the black
death was getting people to boil water
was getting people to bury their dead
this led to a whole new awareness
for sanitation and it's linked with
health
the invention of sanitation the
recognition that we needed to have
sewers that we needed to take
human waste and move it as far as
possible from
human settlements
[Music]
that was in many ways the greatest
invention one would say
of medicine what separates
town dwellers from nomads people who
live in nomadic societies can just get
up and walk away
town dwellers can't and why this is
important
is because town dwellers have to deal
with their own refuse
that required organization it required
politics it required a system of
sanitation
you're seeing the beginnings of what we
now call civic society
if you want to just count the number of
lives saved sanitation
is perhaps one of the greatest
discoveries we've ever made
the plague pandemics are a prime example
of how a lack of knowledge and the
inability to spread
accurate information can lead to false
assumptions
at every turn in our existence the quest
for truth
by examination has provided the key to
our survival
in the face of disaster when we started
to get a clear
picture of our body and how our system
works we discovered
we are not alone we now know we carry
life forms within us
trillions upon trillions many of them
good some of them bad
the first discovery of these microbes
opened a whole new battlefront in the
war against disease
it's a fight that continues today
attacking the origins of illness itself
beating back the specter of death
we know today that our macroscopic world
is controlled by microscopic beings
most of them help us but some microbes
are killers
medical technology is now so powerful we
can see them
in fine details
but in the 19th century doctors had no
idea what caused epidemics of cholera
yellow fever influenza measles diseases
that
ravaged the most sophisticated modern
societies on earth
a lot of the very finest minds put
themselves to the challenge of
understanding the human body and illness
and how they work
but the problem is the human body is a
very complex thing and they didn't
understand
one of the basic mechanisms which is
that a lot of what
determines how healthy we are or not is
is invisible
it's microbial
imagine what it must have been like to
look into a microscope and see for the
first
time organisms invisible to the eye
operating in our blood within our bodies
how would you know if you were looking
at the product of a disease
or its cause
this was the central question facing a
young doctor
working in the outskirts of the german
empire in 1875
his name was robert coke
[Music]
jealousy stuff
[Music]
[Music]
robert koch was a country doctor in a
small town that was filled with sheep
farmers
it had an outbreak of anthrax they asked
him to
find out what was killing the local
sheep so coke started a series of
experiments
robert coke believed the germ theory of
disease that disease could spread by
means of
microbes these things we observed under
microscopes
people had observed bacteria for many
hundreds of years
there was no way to prove that that had
anything to do with
causing the disease in fact it was
thought that they resulted as
a consequence of the disease
they can't just do this hormone this is
talking to this house
foreign
so coke took the blood of the local
sheep
and he moved it to another animal
[Music]
and that animal died
[Music]
he saw bacteria in the blood and had an
outbreak of anthrax
hobbit
has
[Music]
after he had reproduced the disease in
20 or 30 animals
and in each case seen the blood go
from pure and clean to infested with
these pathogens
coke had actually created a chain of
evidence
that had identified that there was in
fact
one bacteria one pathogen that caused
this disease
the germ theory of disease became a true
breakthrough of medicine
right up until the time of [ __ ] a common
notion
was that maladies were caused by bad air
miasmas as they were known i mean
malaria means
bad air it just seems so
counter-intuitive the idea that
something
small and invisible could make you ill
and even
kill you eventually robert koch started
to
make this amazing pattern of discoveries
typhus
anthrax tuberculosis all these diseases
that caused millions of deaths a year
were suddenly catalogued and identified
as being caused by bacteria
and so robert coke signs up to give a
lecture in a library in berlin
the doctors in the room were there to
challenge coke they had staked their
careers
on arguing against germs and he finished
his lecture
and the room was completely silent
[Music]
paul ehrlich another famous scientist
who was in the room said he knew
that he had witnessed a pivotal moment
in medical history and the world had
suddenly changed
the ability to identify and prevent
infectious diseases
is the key to almost all of modern
medical science
without it humanity can die in a matter
of months
the germ theory of disease led us to the
creation of vaccines
and that was a pivotal moment we haven't
yet conquered death
obviously but one of the things we have
conquered
thanks to vaccinations is the insane
infant mortality rate that used to exist
a hundred years ago families had to be
of
three four five seven children because
at least half of them weren't going to
make it to adulthood
and of course it prevented women from
having careers having lives outside of
the family
but thanks to vaccinations we can be
pretty sure that the children we give
birth to
are going to make it suddenly you now
only need to have one or two children
women
are no longer just baby machines they
are human beings
so you have the rise of feminism you get
the rise of the middle classes
so in fact there's this huge social
revolution
that comes out of this medical
revolution
the collective wisdom of all of
humankind led to the medical
advancements that made us
modern we're attacking the things that
harm us on a microscopic level
we're finding new ways of preventing
disease every day
the question is how far can we go
what seems to be fantasy and sci-fi in
the world of health and the human body
is actually just right around the corner
imagine having your own personal catalog
of replacement tissue
sitting on a shelf we can tweak a skin
cell
and turn it into a brain cell and
rebuild your body parts
that's the horizon and it's not far away
it's not 50 years away
it's going on right now
this lab is to genetics what the
printing press was to written work
here in this lab we synthesize dna
so a lot of people have heard about the
human genome project where dna was
decoded
but here what we're doing is actually
building pieces of dna
the dna code in every cell it's not only
a source of information
for example your eye color your hair
color your height but it's also a source
of control of different processes in
your body things like
regenerating cells at different speeds
and different parts of your body
it's an incredible incredible technology
our overarching goal is making dna
ubiquitous to make it available to
everyone
[Music]
the things that we're working on right
now we know can be game changing
better more specific drugs personalized
drugs
we're enabling a lot of different types
of projects
but i always like to think about the
people that are studying cancer there's
been a lot of cancer
in my family cancer is a very
dynamic disease but if you can
accelerate
research then you can actually create a
designer therapy for a specific tumor
and the faster you can do that the
earlier you can intervene and that's
everything in cancer
[Music]
in the world of synthetic biology it's
either going to be the thing that saves
humanity or the thing that kills
humanity
so we're part of an organization that
self-polices in the industry
we have different protocols to ensure
that none of us will design
and build something harmful to humanity
i think as we think about medicine this
is the next revolution in medicine
this is the ability to really create
personalized medicine
it's an opportunity to help humankind
with the discovery of dna and the
mechanisms of genetics we have
discovered the language of life we have
realized that we are linguistic all the
way down
dna is code and we are diving deeper
into what makes us uniquely
human we are repairing flaws that have
built up
over millennia of evolution so we can
chase off
death and thrive in this modern world
today
and beyond tomorrow as alan harrington
once wrote any philosophy
that accepts death must itself be
considered dead
it's questions meaningless it's
consolations
worn out
[Music]
across time the advancement of medicine
has done
more than save lives it has given us a
new understanding of ourselves
and our world
[Music]
we have grasped the inner workings of
our bodies and our minds
we have gazed upon the very building
blocks of life
the clockwork of biology that makes us
tick
we have even discovered an entirely new
way of thinking
through medicine powerful ideas about
logic and reason have taken root
and blossomed into science
[Music]
even when the unknown outweighed the
known
even as we fought an invisible enemy
we refused to accept the inevitable
with medicine we have seized our own
faith
we owe it all to the visionaries of
medicine
the healers and thinkers who paved the
way
we have come far our species is on the
verge of medical revolutions that will
change what it means to be human
as we turn to face the future we fight
death
with more power than ever before
standing on the shoulders
of giants we are ready to face the
[Music]
unknown
[Music]
we will fight until we see the end of
disease
and just maybe the end
of death
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you